welcome back y'all our next guest knows
what it's like to be surrounded by the
extraordinary her dad Clarence known as
the black Godfather was the chairman of
mtown Records no big deal her mom
Jacqueline which I love that name um was
a huge activist and philanthropist in
South Central Los Angeles um and she's a
Powerhouse in her own ride as well her
new book is called think you'll be happy
moving through grief with grit gratitude
and Grace great title great subject
matter let's everybody welcome back
Nicole Avon come
on so welcome welcome back to the show
thank yes I so I have to writing a book
is such a huge thing like I don't know
if I'd ever do something like that it's
so hard and it's you've got to be so
vulnerable and a lot has happened in
your life like even since this is you
you started the book and then throughout
it so how do you deal like the loss of
your dad like and going through this
book and being honest you know the
writing help helps as I'm sure a lot of
you guys know writing and I'm sure you
too when you write it out like for a
song it gets all of your emotions out it
helps you own what you're feeling it's
almost like you recognize what you're
you recognize what you're feeling by
writing it out that's why journaling
works you know and and so yes it was
hard writing the book but it was hard in
a good way it was challenging and I had
already been writing a book you know
before anything happened with my mom and
my dad and I written it after the black
Godfather I thought the themes grit
gratitude and Grace yeah came out of the
documentary the black Godfather and
that's what I was going to write and
then we actually did a I was on the show
and you ended and you know when you end
a zoom and it says leave now we didn't
actually leave and you said she should
write a book and I was just I had just
started gr gratitude and Grace and you
were the one who gave me the fuel I kept
saying I don't know how to write this I
don't know what I'm doing and you did
that for me so you are a because when
you listen to you speak about it you're
such a great speaker and you're so
vulnerable not everybody is able to go
to that place like that's a very hard
place to go to but what I find
interesting is so you were already
writing you lose your mama you lost your
daddy there's so much that happened and
they weren't that far apart like so much
to happen while you're writing this so
it definitely had to alter the book it
altered the book completely I so like I
said I was starting on grit Grace and
gratitude and then my mom unfortunately
was killed and it was so shocking and
traumatic as anything would be like that
and I naturally my human instinct was
okay I'm just going to leave this for a
while people will understand why I'm not
continuing to write I go how am I going
to put a book out on grit Grace and
gratitude and my mom just died yeah and
then somebody on my team said but wait a
minute you know let's let's think about
Jackie could be throughout this book and
her last text to me was think you'll be
happy those are the Last Words My mom
said to me think you'll be happy and we
just moved it all together and went wait
a minute that's the title of the book
because it is the Mantra that she gave
me yeah to live my life it's amazing to
me to think about everything changed and
I'm a person that thinks everything
happens for a reason even if it's
horrible and it's one of those things is
like how in incredibly magical that they
still live on through this book that you
were writing that was supposedly about
something El and now it becomes
something bigger than that and so much
more helpful by the way to all the
people that are going through such grief
and L I agree and cuz grief comes in
different waves as we all know right oh
I think divorce is grief grief it's a
death and relationships die and dogs die
and parents die and children or no one
has to die grief is you could lose a job
that you Lov so much and all of a sudden
you're fired you lose something but but
like I say in the book it is the receipt
grief is the receipt that you loved that
you love something cuz if you didn't you
wouldn't this is why I told her to write
a book
it's a bumper sticket I'm like what I
would wear that on a shirt as a reminder
it it is a that you've loved and you've
been loved hopefully and that's really
what this journey of life is all of us
are going to feel grief all of us are
going to feel sadness to know that it's
inevitable it's inevitable trials and
tribulations come to everybody yeah and
so I I was hoping that this book kind of
yes it's about moving through grief of
course but it also is about living this
book is about life this book is about
survival and Legacy and love and
compassion and serving others you know
and I just Ed my mom feel so great yes
so I use I was able to take the pain
that I felt for what happened to my mom
and I thought well the best way I can
honor her is to live a full life and do
things that made her happy so that
continues her Legacy and that make you
happy and talk about her yeah and I
never never wanted anyone to forget
Jacqueline Avon and I thought you know
what if there's all this news about my
mom and it's so
Sensational then I'm going to write her
story I'm GNA talk about Jacqueline Avon
but who would know it best right you
know so it's a beautiful book and it's
it's going to be helpful to so many it's
a lot of hardship you had to go through
but it's a beautiful thing to be able to
use that your testimony yes thank you
yeah oh my gosh Nicole's book think
you'll be happy is out now got to get
yourself a
[Music]
[Applause]
copy thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home